Tatütata, die Feuerwehr
ist da! (Ja.) Hallo Manuel.
Hallo Cari.
Also früher ist die Feuerwehr ja bei uns nur
unfreiwillig durchgefahren, weil ich an einer
sehr lauten Straße wohnte und jetzt hast du
sie durchfahren lassen. Wie kommt das denn?
Richtig. Heute war es ein Spezial-Soundeffekt,
denn: Herzlich willkommen zu
Episode 112 von unserem Podcast.
112? Was bedeutet das denn, Manuel?
112, das ist nicht nur unsere
Episodennummer, sondern das ist auch unser …
Mensch, Manuel. Das ist aber gewitzt,
dass wir das jetzt miteinander verbinden,
das Episodenthema und das Thema der
Woche. 112 ist eine Telefonnummer.
Richtig, eine sehr kurze Telefonnummer. Und in
Amerika ist es die 911 und in Europa, nicht nur in
Deutschland, ist es 112. Das ist der Notruf. Damit
erreicht man die Feuerwehr und den Krankenwagen.
Und zwar in ganz Europa, wie ich ja
vor Kurzem erst gelernt habe. Ich bin
allerdings nicht alleine: Einundsiebzig
Prozent der Menschen wissen nicht,
dass man in der ganzen EU mit
112 die Feuerwehr anrufen kann.
Das ist verrückt. Dann leisten wir jetzt
hiermit sozusagen einen Beitrag, dass das
mehr Menschen hoffentlich lernen. Wie ist das denn
bei dir, Cari? Hast du schon mal die 112 gewählt?
Selten tatsächlich. Ich habe aber, einmal habe ich
tatsächlich 112 angerufen, als ich einen Notfall
wahrnahm. Die 112 kann man ja immer anrufen bei
verschiedenen Notfällen. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel
ein Haus brennt, kann man die anrufen, aber auch,
wenn jemand vielleicht umgekippt ist und man einen
Rettungswagen braucht. Und wir hatten tatsächlich
eine krasse Geschichte erlebt: Ich war mit Janusz
in der U-Bahn in Berlin … ich glaube, ich habe die
Geschichte sogar schon mal irgendwann erzählt hier
im Podcast. Erinnerst du dich? (Kann sein, ja.)
Ja, auf jeden Fall saßen wir in der U-Bahn und da
ist plötzlich jemand, der lag auf einem Sitz, der
sah aus, als würde er schlafen und dann ist der
einfach so vom Sitz gerollt und mit dem Kopf
richtig auf den, auf dem Boden aufgeschlagen
und hat sich danach nicht bewegt. Und das
hat natürlich Leuten Angst gemacht, der ist
dann immer so hin und her gerollt auf dem
Fußboden. Dann ist mal jemand dahingegangen,
hat versucht ihn anzusprechen, ohne Erfolg und
dann sa… da saßen irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
zehn Leute in diesem Waggon und keiner wusste, was
er machen sollte. Und dann dachte ich, ja, okay,
dann, bevor wir jetzt nichts machen, habe ich dann
den Notruf angerufen, 112. Und da war ich dann,
obwohl wir in einem Tunnel waren, verbunden
mit einem Rettungsdienst und der hat mir dann
Instruktionen gegeben. Der hat gesagt: "Gehen
Sie da mal hin und kneifen Sie diesen Mann in den
Oberarm." Kneifen ist auf Englisch … (to pinch.)
Genau, das wusste ich nicht. Kneifen, also eine,
ja, sehr stark, vielleicht wehtun. Und das habe
ich dann gemacht. Ich habe diesen Mann gekniffen,
nachdem wir ja schon versucht haben, mit ihm
zu sprechen. Er ist nicht aufgewacht. Dann habe
ich, ich war ja noch am Telefon, habe dem Mann
gesagt: "Ja, es ist nichts passiert." Da meinte
er: "Machen Sie das noch mal so doll, wie Sie
können." Wieder nichts passiert und dann hat er
so ganz nüchtern, ganz neutral gesagt: "Ja, dann
bleibt Ihnen jetzt nur noch eins, Frau Schmid:
Sie müssen jetzt die Notbremse betätigen." Und
ich so: "Oh mein Gott! Ich? Die Notbremse von dem
Zug?" Und dann habe ich die Notbremse gezogen und
dann kam erst mal so eine, dann ist der, der … ich
weiß gar nicht mehr, ob der Zug sofort gestoppt
ist. Auf jeden Fall kam dann eine Durchsage von
dem Schaffner und der sagte nur: "Wer hat hier die
Notbremse gezogen?", weil das wahrscheinlich viele
auch als Scherz machen. Und dann habe ich gesagt,
so: "Ja, ich bin im Wagen ganz hinten und hier ist
jemand ohnmächtig oder bewusstlos und ich habe
schon den Rettungsdienst angerufen, der hat mir
gesagt, die Notbremse zu ziehen." Und dann hat
der durchgesagt durch den ganzen Wagen: "Ja, wir
werden jetzt in den nächsten Bahnhof einfahren,
damit der Rettungsdienst kommen kann und wenn
es Ärzte im Zug gibt, sollen die bitte in den
Waggon kommen." Und dann kamen gleich dre… nee,
fünf Ärzte kamen direkt in den Waggon und die
haben dann eben geguckt, ob es dem, ja, ob er noch
atmet und so und tatsächlich hat der Mann noch
geatmet, aber war nicht ansprechbar. Also man weiß
nicht, was mit ihm passiert ist, ob das jetzt ein
medizinischer Notfall war oder vielleicht Drogen,
Alkohol im Spiel waren, das … so was passiert
natürlich in Berlin. Ja. Und dann, das Krasse,
was dann eigentlich passiert ist, ist, dass ein
Rettungsdienst kam, den abgeholt hat und die waren
sauer, dass überhaupt jemand den Rettungsdienst
gerufen hat, weil aus ihrer Sicht war das kein
medizinischer Notfall, sondern ein Betrunkener,
der … ja. Und dann haben die tatsächlich so
gefragt, "wer hat hier den Rettungsdienst
gerufen?" und waren ziemlich schlecht drauf.
Das finde ich ein bisschen schade zu hören, weil
ich oft gesagt bekommen habe und auch in den
Erste Hilfe-Kursen, die ich zum Beispiel gemacht
habe — ich habe mehrere schon machen können — da
wird immer gesagt: Es ist immer besser, im
Zweifel etwas zu machen als nichts zu machen,
selbst wenn man nicht genau weiß, was
ist jetzt das Richtige? Mindestens
anrufen und irgendwas machen. Die Person
ansprechen ist immer besser als zu sagen,
"das ist mir jetzt zu gefährlich, ich
mache jetzt lieber gar nichts", insofern.
Ja und das ist ja auch strafbar. Es gibt ja
diesen, im Deutschen diesen Begriff "unterlassene
Hilfeleistung", also eine Hilfe, die unterlassen
wird, also die nicht gemacht wird. Und wenn man
zum Beispiel sich bei einem Unfall oder irgendwo
entfernt, wo jemand gerade in einem Notfall ist,
dann … ich weiß nicht genau, was das für
rechtliche Konsequenzen hat, aber es ist auf jeden
Fall, ja, sowohl rechtlich als auch moralisch,
moralisch allein schon schwierig zu sagen:
"Ich gehe jetzt einfach weg." Und das ist mir auch
so direkt in den Kopf gekommen. Es gab mal einen
bekannten Fall, wo in einer Sparkasse ein Mann
kollabiert ist mit einem, weiß ich gar nicht,
ein Herzinfarkt oder so und der Mann tatsächlich
in einer Bank gestorben ist am Tag und kein Mensch
da war oder kein Mensch ihn angesprochen hat, weil
alle dachten, das wäre vielleicht ein Betrunkener,
der einfach auf dem Fußboden schläft.
Und so was ist natürlich tragisch,
deshalb würde ich auch jeden ermutigen … und
das haben dann später auch Leute gemacht,
nachdem die weg waren mit ihrer
schlechten Laune und dem Typen,
kamen dann tatsächlich mehrere Leute im Zug
zu mir und haben gesagt, so: "Ja, danke,
dass du das gemacht hast. Du hast das Richtige
gemacht." Und ich würde das auch wieder tun.
Das denke ich auch. Gut.
Manuel, hast du denn schon mal
den Rettungsdienst rufen müssen?
Ja, ich habe sogar mal, also auch die 112
gerufen, um die Feuerwehr zu erreichen.
Und zwar war das vor ein paar Jahren, da ist
meine Mutter in ein neues Haus gezogen und wir
mussten dieses Haus erst mal renovieren.
Ich habe da bei der Renovierung geholfen
und wir haben da den ganzen Tag gearbeitet
und gestreicht und das war natürlich noch …
Gestrichen.
Gestrichen, gestrichen. Habe gerade schon
überlegt, ist das gestreicht oder gestrichen?
Also, liebe Deutschlerner, das ist auch als
Deutscher manchmal nicht so ganz leicht. Also,
wir haben den ganzen Tag die Wände gestrichen,
wir haben da alles Mögliche gemacht. Und dann war
es schon ziemlich spät abends, es war schon dunkel
und wir hörten so Zisch-Geräusche immer im Keller,
so ein ganz komisches Zisch-Geräusch. Und dann
sind wir heruntergegangen und es roch nach Gas.
Es roch einfach nach Gas und wir dachten: "Oh
scheiße, also, das ist natürlich nicht gut,
diese Geräusche und dieser Gasgeruch",
aber es war auch so eine Situation,
wo wir uns natürlich nicht sicher
sind: War das jetzt wirklich was?
Und ich habe dann die 112 gerufen und habe
diese Situation geschildert und habe gesagt,
so: "Könnten Sie vielleicht mal eine Person
vorbeischicken, die sich das mal anguckt?"
Das haben die mit Sicherheit. Eine
Person, die mal zum Gucken kommen.
Richtig. Er meinte dann so ganz trocken, so:
"Nee, also wenn wir kommen, dann kommen wir
richtig und das machen wir dann jetzt." Und
dann kamen wirklich zwei oder drei so richtig
riesige Feuerwehrautos, ja? Also ich weiß nicht,
wie die, wie die heißen. Das sind ja wirklich
so Mannschaftswagen, in jedem Wagen irgendwie
sechs Leute drin. Die kamen dann da vorgefahren,
das ist auch auf dem Land und natürlich die
ganze Nachbarschaft irgendwie am Fenster. Und
dann kamen die heraus und sind in das Haus rein,
auch ganz vorsichtig mit so Spezial-Taschenlampen,
haben keine Lichter angemacht, haben erst
mal alle Fenster aufgerissen und so und
haben dann auch gerochen. Und mindestens einer
von denen meinte dann auch so: "Ja, also, für
mich riecht es auch nach Gas." Und die haben dann
einen Spezial-Menschen aus dem Bett geklingelt,
der kam dann irgendwie aus der nächstgelegenen
Stadt mit einem speziellen Messgerät. Das dauerte
dann erst mal zwanzig Minuten, bis der kam und
der lief dann mit dem Messgerät durch das Haus,
hat alles gemessen und hat dann die Entwarnung
gegeben, also es war dann kein Gas. Es
stellte sich dann später heraus, dass die, die
Geräusche kamen von so einer Anlage im Keller,
die wir noch nicht kannten, die das Wasser
einfach gefiltert hat. Und der Geruch,
das habe ich dann auch gelernt, der kam von
der trocknenden Farbe. Wenn Farbe trocknet,
dann riecht das so ein bisschen faul manchmal
und das ist so ein ähnlicher Geruch wie Gas.
Und die Feuerwehrleute, die meinten dann nämlich
auch so: "Keine Ursache, wir sind gerne gekommen
und wenn noch mal was ist, einfach wieder
anrufen." Also, die waren ganz entspannt.
Wie nett. Die, also, die sind dann ja wirklich
… aber wenn die das nicht mal selber wussten,
also wenn die einen Spezialisten rufen mussten,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so einfach
gewesen, das festzustellen. Vorsicht ist besser
als Nachsicht, ne? Sagt man ja im Deutschen.
Was noch ganz interessant war bei der Sache,
war, dass das die Freiwillige Feuerwehr war,
die da kam. In Deutschland gibt es
ja eine Berufsfeuerwehr und eine
Freiwillige Feuerwehr. Und die Freiwillige
Feuerwehr, das sind alles Ehrenamtliche,
die machen das einfach, ja, die werden da,
glaube ich, gar nicht für bezahlt oder?
Richtig. Das sind Ehrenamtliche und trotzdem aber
Profis, also die ausgebildet werden. Und manchmal
haben die auch tatsächlich hauptamtliche Leute,
also Menschen, die das hauptberuflich machen.
Ich habe mich da mal ein bisschen eingelesen vor
unserer Episode und habe auch einen Link als Tipp,
wo man ein bisschen was über die Geschichte der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr lesen kann. Und ich wusste
gar nicht, dass in Deutschland siebzig Prozent
der Feuerwehr Freiwillige Feuerwehr ist. Und das
ist ziemlich interessant, diese ganze Geschichte.
Die Freiwillige Feuerwehr gibt es noch gar nicht,
also gibt es schon so, glaube ich, zweihundert
Jahre, aber davor waren die Leute selber dafür
zuständig, ihr Haus zu löschen, was natürlich
ein bisschen doof ist, weil wenn … je nachdem,
wie viele Leute da jetzt bei dir sind oder
im Haus wohnen oder gerade verfügbar sind,
ist das natürlich eine schwierige Angelegenheit.
Und da ist die Freiwillige Feuerwehr,
die sich gegenseitig hilft, natürlich gut. Also,
habe ich einen Link in den Show Notes, falls
euch das interessiert, die Geschichte der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr in Deutschland. Gibt
es auch in anderen Ländern und kommt wohl
ursprünglich aus Frankreich, das Konzept.
Interessant. Ja, also was ist unser
Fazit für heute? Im Zweifel anrufen oder?
Im Zweifelsfall die Feuerwehr rufen, genau. Und
das ist ja auch so, da ist ja jemand am Telefon
dann, der dich berät. Also, du musst keine Angst
haben, dass dann, dass du jemanden nervst, auch
wenn das vielleicht in meinem Fall so war, dass
die dann genervt reagiert haben, aber da ist ja
jemand am Telefon, der genau fragt: "Wo bist du?
Was ist passiert?" Der auch darauf trainiert ist,
in Notfällen mit Menschen zu kommunizieren. Und
der wird dann ja mit dir die Entscheidung treffen,
was zu tun ist, ob dann jemand wirklich kommt
oder nicht. Insofern: Im Zweifelsfall anrufen.
Manuel. (Cari.) Ich mag unsere Empfehlungen.
Ich freue mich immer über Empfehlungen,
auch in anderen Podcasts und ich
dachte, ich frage dich heute mal:
Was hast du eigentlich zuletzt "gebinget"?
Gebinget? Du meinst damit keine
Drogen und keinen Alkohol,
vermute ich, denn du weißt, ich trinke sehr wenig.
Kann man dieses Wort auch für
Alkohol und Drogen benutzen?
Daher kommt das ja eigentlich. (Ach
echt?) Also es, eigentlich gibt es ja
dieses Binge-Drinking, ich kenne das aus Amerika.
Guck mal, so was weiß ich gar nicht, ne? Das weiß
ich gar nicht. Es gibt aber, tatsächlich ist das
im Deutschen nur übernommen worden im Sinne
von "Binge-Watching" und natürlich wird dieser
Begriff wie auch alle anderen Verben, die aus
dem Englischen übernommen werden, eingedeutscht,
also mit den deutschen Endungen versehen.
Gebinget. Hast du wieder was gebinget die Tage?
Ich binge tatsächlich gerade etwas, und zwar
"The Office", die amerikanische Version von "The
Office". Ich hatte das nie gesehen in meinem, in
meinem ganzen Leben, aber meine Freundin ist ein
großer Fan und wir schauen gerade von vorne
bis hinten alle vierzehn Staffeln durch und
es ist wirklich verdammt lustig. Es ist sehr
schön und eine, meine Empfehlung wäre aber
neben dem amerikanischen "The Office" — und das
britische soll auch sehr gut sein — das deutsche
"The Office". Das wissen nämlich viele nicht,
dass es das auch gibt oder gab. Und das heißt
"Stromberg". Ist ein ganz anderer Humor, ist auch
vom Gefühl her ganz anders, aber es ist eben das
gleiche Konzept. Also es ist auch ein Büro,
ein Versicherungsbüro und so ein verstecktes
Kamerateam, was die ganze Zeit die Leute verfolgt
und so ein Chef, der halt unmöglich ist und immer
total die fürchterlichen, sexistischen und
rassistischen Sprüche macht und Witze macht,
aber eigentlich niemandem was Böses will, mit dem
man eigentlich die ganze Zeit so Mitleid hat. Und
das ist, glaube ich, wenn man deutschen Humor so
verstehen will, eine gute Empfehlung. Stromberg.
Stimmt. Nicht nur deutschen Humor, sondern auch
diese deutsche Bürokratie wird dort perfekt
abgebildet. Also, Leute, die immer tausendmal
erst mal überlegen müssen, nachfragen müssen,
die ganz genaue Abläufe mögen. Es wird nichts
spontan gemacht. Und aber auch so ein bisschen
diese deutsche Kultur, dass man dann im Büro auch
mal ein Glas Sekt trinkt zum Mittagessen und dann
so sich zwingen muss, so Humor zu haben, ne, mit
Karneval und solchen Geschichten. Also wirklich
sehr gut, obwohl es schon alt ist. Bis wann sind
denn die amerikanischen Office-Staffeln gegangen?
Das weiß ich nicht. Auch schon länger her.
Ich binge gerade was ganz Aktuelles,
Manuel und möchte dir das gerne
empfehlen — und allen anderen,
die auf so was Bock haben. Ich gucke jetzt
die, gerade die vierte Staffel von "The Crown",
die gerade am Sonntag herausgekommen ist und habe
direkt am ersten Tag drei Folgen durchgebinget.
Erzähl, worum geht es da?
Es geht um die britische …
Hast du das schon mal geguckt?
… Thronfolge oder so oder?
Nee, habe ich noch nie geguckt.
Genau, es geht um die, eigentlich um
die Königsfamilie in England über die
verschiedenen Jahrzehnte. Für jedes
Jahrzehnt gibt es eine Staffel und
das ist jetzt das vierte Jahrzehnt. Das fängt
1979 an und spielt in den Achtzigern. Es gibt
Sechziger, nee, Fünfziger, Sechziger, Siebziger,
Achtziger, die vierte Staffel. Das heißt,
es kommen noch zwei, drei, vier, nee, vier. Und
ich muss sagen, ich habe es auch schon versucht,
Isi nahezulegen. Isi, liebe Grüße, du hörst ja
gerade hinter den Kulissen zu. Und es geht im
Prinzip darum, es ist toll, weil es ist extrem
aufwendig gemacht, also es ist wirklich wie
ein Spielfilm produziert mit richtig guter
Kamera, guten Szenen, guten Darstellern.
Und es spielt historische Ereignisse nach, wo man
eigentlich denkt: "Okay, was ist denn passiert?"
Ist ja gar nicht so viel passiert, aber es ist ja
unglaublich viel passiert in den … Also, du musst
dir vorstellen, die fünfziger Jahre, die
sechziger Jahre in jeweils zehn Stunden,
aus britischer Sicht und quasi die Royal Family
oder die Königsfamilie sind halt der Centerpunkt
oder das, ja, der Fokus des Geschehens,
aber es geht dann eben um alles. Um alles,
was halt sowieso in dieser Zeit passiert und von
Kolonialismus über der erste, die erste, das erste
Aufkommen von Smog in den fünfziger, sechziger
Jahren, wo ganz viele Unfälle passiert sind.
All so was wusste ich gar nicht. Jetzt geht es
gerade um die IRA und die Unabhängigkeitsbewegung
in Irland. Und ich muss sagen, ich gucke das
und habe gleichzeitig immer Wikipedia auf und
lese die ganze Geschichte Großbritanniens noch mal
nach. Und es ist einfach gut gemacht und spannend.
Ja, Cari. Da hast du mir Lust
gemacht, das auch mal anzuschauen.
Ja.
Es kommt auf meine lange Liste an
Serien, die ich gerne gucken möchte.
Berichte mir mal.
So, bevor wir gleich wieder eure Fragen
entgegennehmen, also diejenigen, die jetzt
live im Livestream schauen: Ihr könnt uns alles
fragen. Schreibt eure Fragen einfach in den Chat,
aber davor haben wir einen kleinen
Hinweis und eine kleine Bitte, denn:
Wir könnten das hier alles gar nicht
machen, wenn wir nicht so viele tolle
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer hätten, die uns
als Mitglied unterstützen. Und wir dachten,
wir zeigen euch heute mal — jetzt wo wir hier
schon die Kamera haben und auch was zeigen
können — was ihr als Mitglied im Gegenzug auch
bekommt, wenn ihr ein Mitglied von Easy German
werdet. Und zwar bekommt ihr für den Podcast dann
zu jeder Episode ein interaktives Transkript,
das sieht so aus. Also da könnt ihr dann den
Podcast hören und während ihr hört, scrollt er
durch und zeigt jedes einzelne Wort markiert.
Also das ist wirklich sehr gut, um dem Text
folgen zu können und es ist hier sogar so eine
Übersetzungsfunktion mit dabei. Das heißt, ihr
könnt tatsächlich jeden Absatz auch übersetzen.
Jetzt habe ich hier gerade Spanisch eingestellt,
die Sprache könnt ihr euch auch aussuchen. Und
was ihr noch hier daneben seht, dieses, diese
Vokabeln, das ist die Vokabelhilfe. Das heißt, ihr
könnt auch auf dem Handy beim Zuhören, da seht ihr
dann immer eine Liste mit den wichtigsten Vokabeln
aus der aktuellen Minute und die Übersetzung auf
Englisch. Und das ändert sich dann jede Minute
und das ist eine gute Hilfe beim Lernen. Genau.
Manuel, ich habe auch noch was. Ich möchte
mich noch mal bedanken bei unseren Patrons,
natürlich bei all unseren Mitgliedern,
aber ganz besonders bei unseren neuen
Patrons in unserem Donation Membership
Tier. Und zwar haben wir dazu aufgerufen,
dass ihr uns auch Equipment sponsern
könnt und das hat zum Beispiel Rick
gemacht. Und ich habe mir ganz stolz, das
ist mein größter Spaß diese Woche gewesen,
ich habe mir eine Etikettiermaschine bestellt.
Hast du das schon mal gesehen? Das sieht aus wie
ein Ufo und hier ist das Geräusch. Oh, bin ich
ans Mikrofon gekommen. Klingt gar nicht so toll.
Hier stanze ich gerade einen Buchstaben ein, in
eine, in einen … wie nennt man das? In eine Etik…
Auf ein Etikett.
Auf ein Etikett, ja. Auf Englisch heißt
das Labelmaker und unter anderem haben
wir jetzt ein Mikrofon, von
Rick aus den USA gesponsert,
und wir bekleben die dann auch und das ist
mein großer Spaß. Danke an alle von euch.
Vielen Dank und wenn ihr schon
Mitglied seid, dann denk bitte daran,
dass ihr diesen Monat eure Mitgliedschaft
einmal aktualisieren müsst. Geht da bitte
einfach auf unsere Webseite
und da steht, wie das geht.
Damit würdet ihr uns eine große Freude machen.
Manuel. (Ja, Cari.) Du hast ja gerade
die spanischen Untertitel gezeigt und
wir haben da direkt eine Frage für dich. Wir
überfallen dich jetzt mal, aber ich weiß,
dass du so fließend in Spanisch bist, dass
du das ganz spontan beantworten kannst. Und
zwar möchte Ornella unbedingt hören: "Können
wir hören, wie Manuel auf Spanisch spricht?"
¡Hola Ornella! ¿Cómo estás? Mi español es
más o menos. Aprendí en México. ¡Saludos!
Oh, das habe ich sogar verstanden.
Ja, das war jetzt Basislevel, aber ich
lerne schon seit sehr langer Zeit Spanisch,
also mittlerweile ist das auf einem okayen Niveau.
Ja, ich kann auch Spanisch
sprechen: Hola, yo soy Cari.
Weißt du, was witzig ist? Janusz lernt jetzt auch
Spanisch und immer wenn er mir jetzt Nachrichten
schreibt, private Nachrichten einfach an
mich, dann schreibt er die auf Polnisch,
übersetzt die mit DeepL auf Spanisch und schickt
mir die in Spanisch zur Übung. Es ist sehr lustig.
Das ist so geil. Das passt ja super zur Frage von
Martin. Martin fragt: "Wo ist Janusz und worüber
philosophiert er heute?" Janusz ist tatsächlich
in seinem Zimmer hier bei mir nebenan und er
guckt uns gerade zu, also, liebe Grüße an Janusz,
und wir werden ihn bald wieder in unserem Podcast
zu Gast haben. Er philosophiert viel, jeden
Tag, also das kann man schon sagen. Und sein
neues Lieblingsthema ist, an dem er diese Woche
arbeitet, Bücher. Und zwar haben wir Menschen auf
der Straße gefragt diese Woche: "Was ist eure
Buchempfehlung?" Und zwar auch speziell für
Menschen, die Deutsch lernen. Und das seht ihr am
Sonntag bei Easy German, Janusz' neues Thema. Und
Janusz hat sich schon selber eine Liste gemacht
mit Bücher-Tipps, die er für Deutschlerner hat.
Und dann meinte ich so eben zu ihm: "Ja, wo willst
du denn diese Liste posten?" Da meinte er so, ja,
die will er Sonntagabend alle in die Kommentare
unter das Easy German-Video schreiben.
Sehr gut. Das passt zur Frage von Chetan:
"Lesen Sie auch ein Buch gerade oder haben
Sie eine Empfehlung?" Das Problem ist, ich lese
fast nur Bücher auf Englisch, deswegen sind das
keine guten Empfehlungen für Deutschlerner, aber
ich lese unter anderem gerade ein fantastisches
und sehr bekanntes Buch, das heißt "A (People's)
History of the United States". Und da geht es um
die Geschichte der Vereinigten Staaten. Finde
ich gerade in diesem Moment sehr interessant.
Für Deutschlerner dann hoffentlich im
Easy German-Video mehr Empfehlungen.
Das ist ein guter Tipp. Dann hat Aleksi
geschrieben: "Liebe Grüße aus Finnland."
Liebe Grüße nach Finnland, da war ich
noch nie. Warst du schon mal in Finnland?
Leider nicht, aber es ist ganz weit oben
auf meiner Liste. Es muss wunderschön
sein und ich mag Skandinavien generell sehr gerne.
Wo warst du schon in Skandinavien?
In Schweden, in Dänemark … ich glaube, das war es.
Ja. Dann fehlt noch Finnland und Norwegen.
Ja, er schreibt: "Wie kann man euch in Berlin
treffen? Schickt man euch eine Nachricht oder
soll man außerhalb eures Büros Cari schreien?"
Cari ist selten da. Also du
kannst es mal probieren, aber.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Taktik, sich
vor das Büro stellen und "Cari" schreien. Ich
bin wirklich sehr selten im Büro. Jetzt seit
der Corona-Zeit eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr,
muss ich sagen. Und ansonsten, ja, ist
das einfach wegen Corona im Moment so,
dass man uns nicht so oft trifft. Man
kann uns manchmal auf der Straße treffen,
ansonsten organisieren wir gerade nichts. Es
ist ja auch ein Lockdown in Deutschland. Und ich
freue mich schon sehr wieder auf das nächste
Jahr, denn wir haben eigentlich regelmäßige
Treffen mit unseren Zuschauern in einer Kneipe
in Berlin und das war immer sehr nett, Manuel.
(Das stimmt.) Das ist ja immer größer geworden
und ich muss sagen, ich freue mich unheimlich,
wieder … das ist eine der Sachen, die ich am
meisten vermisse jetzt während dieser Corona-Zeit.
Das haben wir jetzt seit acht Monaten nicht mehr
gemacht. Nächstes Jahr gibt es ganz große Treffen.
Richtig. Eventuell, wir versprechen jetzt
noch nichts, aber eventuell — apropos
Mitgliedschaft — wollen wir versuchen,
mit einigen unseren Mitgliedern demnächst
mal ein virtuelles Meetup zu machen. Es gibt ja
diesen Community Membership bei uns auf Patreon,
aber das können wir noch nicht versprechen, aber
wir würden wirklich gerne Meetups wieder machen.
Huch, da habe ich ein Stück von
meinem Labelmaker von meinem
Etikett auf dem Pullover.
Ganz uninteressant, aber.
"Was ist unser Highlight
der Woche?" Mein Highlight
der Woche … Moment, ich zeige es dir kurz.
Okay, das kann man jetzt nicht sehen, wenn
man diesen Podcast nicht bei YouTube sieht,
aber ihr könnt es hören. Kannst du
das Geräusch noch mal machen, Manuel?
Ich habe einen neuen Schreibtisch und es
ist ein Steh-Schreibtisch, den man zwischen
stehen und sitzen immer hin und her elektrisch
stellen kann. Und das habe ich mir gegönnt und
das ist ganz fantastisch. Das Arbeiten hat
ein, eine neue Qualität erreicht bei mir.
Ja und Manuel macht immer Witze
damit in unseren Meetings,
dass er einfach plötzlich den Schreibtisch
hochfährt und dann sieht man seinen Kopf,
wie sein Kopf immer kleiner wird und
der Schreibtisch am, also quasi auch
der Laptop wegfährt von Manuel. Kann man
sich viele Scherze mit erlauben. Manuel,
hier ist eine ganz dringende Frage von
Denis: "Was ist deine Meinung zu Star Trek?"
Da mache ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich keine
Freunde mit, aber ich bin weder ein Star Wars-
noch ein Star Trek-Fan. Ich bin also eigentlich
gar kein Nerd, das war nur ein Gerücht. Ich konnte
mich nie mit diesen Science Fiction-Sachen
so anfreunden. Ich weiß nicht. Magst du das?
Ich habe tatsächlich, ich gucke auch beides
nicht und das ist immer peinlich zuzugeben,
dass ich fast … ich glaube, ich habe einen Star
Wars-Film gesehen und ich weiß nicht mal welchen.
So geht es mir auch.
Aber zum Beispiel, ich weiß, dass ich
das … das ist so etwas, wo ich weiß,
dass ich das irgendwann gerne mal durchgucke und
dann auch Bock drauf habe, also dann werde ich
mal alle Star Wars-Filme nacheinander gucken.
Ich habe tatsächlich früher Star Trek geguckt,
als … ich weiß gar nicht, wie alt ich da
war. Entweder war ich zwölf oder siebzehn,
aber nicht vierzehn. Nee, ich weiß es
nicht mehr, aber ich habe tatsächlich am
Anfang Star Trek geguckt. Da kommt direkt
noch eine Fernsehfrage, die ich auch sehr
gerne beantworte. Katie schreibt: "Habt
ihr die neue ZDF satirische Serie gesehen,
ZDF Magazin Royale? Es ist genauso gut wie die
heute-show." Hast du die schon gesehen, Manuel?
Ja, das ist doch mit Jan Böhmermann oder?
Richtig. Ja, aber hast du es gesehen?
Ach so, jetzt irgendwie diese Woche, nee. Ich
habe das vor einem Jahr oder so mal gesehen.
Richtig, es war vorher bei ZDFneo und hieß das
"Neo Magazin Royale". Dann haben sie fast ein
Jahr Pause gemacht und jetzt bei ZDF nach der
heute-show. Sehr lange hat er darum gekämpft,
in die, zur Prime Time auf dem Hauptsender einen
Sendeplatz zu bekommen. Und ich muss sagen,
dass die erste Folge eher enttäuschend war, die
zweite dafür umso besser. Also ich kann empfehlen,
die letzte Folge vom letzten Freitag zu sehen.
Und ich gucke mir tatsächlich auch beides immer
freitags abends an, die heute-show und das ZDF
Magazin Royale. Deutschland, ich muss sagen,
ist nicht so gut in so, in so Sendungen, wie
einige Sendungen in den USA sind. Und oft ist
das ja so, dass die Formate auch so ein bisschen
kopiert sind. Also, Jan Böhmermann versucht so
was Ähnliches zu machen wie John Oliver zum
Beispiel. Und ganz oft gelingt das auch,
aber auch ganz oft so mittelmäßig. Ja, aber ich
bin schon ein Zuschauer von diesen Formaten.
Takube sagt: "Schon wieder eine Episode
für Rentner." (Was?) Harsche Kritik. Was
haben wir noch? Hier fragt jemand,
ob Schlagermusik, apropos Rentner,
ob Schlagermusik in Deutschland beliebt und
bekannt ist. Hörst du manchmal Schlagermusik?
Nein. Also, bekannt und beliebt ist
sie tatsächlich und das ist etwas,
was viele Deutsche furchtbar finden — wie zum
Beispiel ich — und auch ein bisschen peinlich.
Ich finde deutsche Musik, es gibt schon gute
deutsche Musik, aber insgesamt muss ich sagen,
haben wir auch schon mal im Podcast drüber
gesprochen, wenn man in England ist,
dann hört man in allen Pubs eigentlich gute
Musik aus den letzten fünfzig, sechzig Jahren
bis heute. Und in Deutschland ist es wirklich,
man hat entweder Techno, Schlager oder irgendwie
so was wie Rammstein. Und ich kann mich mit
keinem dieser Musikstile sonderlich anfreunden.
Geht mir ähnlich. Crunxo fragt: "Warum
ist unser Podcast nicht mehr so lange
wie früher?" Das liegt daran, dass wir statt
einmal in der Woche dreimal in der Woche senden,
jedes Mal ungefähr eine halbe Stunde. Also
insgesamt machen wir mehr Podcast als früher.
Und man kann uns öfter hören.
So sieht es aus.
Manuel, da kam gerade noch eine
Frage von Jonathon. Und er fragt:
"Wie funktionieren denn die Rettungsdienste in
Deutschland? Sind die zentral koordiniert oder
ruft man einen spezifischen Dienst
an, zum Beispiel das Rote Kreuz?"
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich glaube, das ist
in jeder Stadt oder in jeder Region gibt es
sozusagen ein Zentrum, was zentral koordiniert
und die koordinieren dann die Rettungswagen,
die von unterschiedlichen
Organisationen betrieben werden.
Genau. Also ja, kann man schon sagen, dass
das zentral koordiniert ist. Man muss sich
jetzt nicht überlegen, rufe ich jetzt beim Roten
Kreuz an oder bei der Berufsfeuerwehr oder der
Freiwilligen Feuerwehr, weil die einem vielleicht
gar nicht antworten. Man hat eine Notfallnummer,
die ruft man an und dann wird man
mit dem verbunden, der … Ich glaube,
die Rettungsstelle ist zentral und die leiten
das dann weiter an den, der verfügbar ist.
Vielleicht machen wir da ja noch mal eine ganze
Sendung drüber, denn ich kenne auch jemanden,
der zum Beispiel Rettungssanitäter ist. Und
ich finde das wirklich ein spannendes Thema.
Super spannendes Thema. Würde
ich auch gerne mal mehr erfahren.
Ja, Cari.
Ich denke immer noch über Takubes Kommentar nach.
Ja. Hat er nicht mit gerechnet,
dass das hier gefeatured wird. Ihr
könnt uns natürlich auch jederzeit Fragen
stellen, wenn wir nicht gerade live senden,
auf easygerman.fm. Da ist unten so ein
Knopf "Eure Fragen", könnt ihr uns auch
eine Sprachnachricht schicken, dann spielen
wir die vielleicht ab im Podcast und genau.
Das sollten wir mal wieder machen, ne? (Das
machen wir.) Eine Sprachnachricht abspielen.
Zum Schluss möchte ich mich noch mal bedanken an
(bei) unser(em) Team hinter den Kulissen. Das ist
nämlich unter anderem Isi, die auch live dabei
ist, aber nicht hier vor der Kamera ist. Ich
hoffe, das wird aber vielleicht nächstes
Mal oder übernächstes Mal der Fall sein,
wenn sie ihr neues Podcast-Equipment bekommt.
Und dann ist da noch Francisco, der hinter den
Kulissen hier alles managt. Francisco, du
kannst mal alle, alle Bilder vertauschen.
Wenn man jetzt gerade auf YouTube zuguckt, dann
sieht man, was Francisco alles Magisches machen
kann. Er kann das Bild groß und klein machen, er
kann uns verwechseln, er kann Sachen einblenden.
Er ist also unser Produktionsmanager. Und
Francisco könnt ihr auch, ansonsten auch bei
Easy Spanish … auch nicht vor der Kamera sehen.
Weiß ich gar nicht, was ich gerade sagen wollte.
Aber seine Arbeit bewundern. Ja, also
er macht das hinter den Kulissen.
Genau, Francisco schneidet quasi
fast alle Easy Spanish-Episoden.
Toll. Schön, Cari. Dann hören
wir uns am Samstag schon wieder
in unserem normalen Podcast. (Verrückt.) Verrückt.
Ja, kannst du zum Ende noch mal
die, noch mal was Schönes spielen?
Ist eigentlich gar nicht so ein gutes Ende, ne?
Ist nicht so ein schönes Ende, aber
egal. Wir verabschieden uns mit Tatütata.
Tatütata, die Feuerwehr ist da! Ist
das eigentlich … Ich habe mich gefragt,
wo das herkommt. Ist das ein Kinderlied?
Das weiß ich nicht. Den Titel hast du dir ja
ausgesucht. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo das herkommt.
Ja, weil man das als Kind immer hört. Ich
glaube, das ist ein Kinderbuch und das,
als Kind … also die, quasi die
Art, wie man das verschriftlicht,
diese Sirene im Deutschen, ist
Tatütata. Das ist eigentlich …
Verrückt.
Total verrückt, Manuel. Okay, ich verabschiede
mich. Ich bin schon ganz hibbelig, ich habe
nämlich heute einen Kaffee getrunken und muss
jetzt erst mal runterkommen mit einem Glas Wasser.
Prost. Bis bald, Cari. Ciao!